all the ambulances have just arrived at
once
so why is this the witching house i
don't know i don't know
late afternoon and seven ambulances are
suddenly stacked up outside
to be uploaded
[Music]
hospital admissions may have dipped
slightly this week
[Music]
we're still in the thick of a crisis
how do you feel at the end of a shift
knackered yeah
kind of the beginning of a shift
domestic worker larissa attanasova
renowned in the hospital for her
machine-like efficiency
can barely clean the bays quickly enough
they call every two minutes what you can
do
nothing the next patient is coming
she's right two minutes later 52 year
old davey and hunt arrived
what were your symptoms to barely walk
yeah lack of energy and tired
i just want to sleep all the time
another patient arrived by ambulance has
gone to the recess area
he's quite sad sorry his wife died on
friday
while he was being treated in here oh my
god
one two three 63 year old post office
cleaner
felix ramen lost his wife four days ago
now he has dangerously low oxygen levels
it's going to be a little bit tighter
but it will help you to breathe
nurses say this cpap machine is like
sticking your head
out of a car window at 90 miles an hour
and opening your mouth
is it coming up yeah it is coming up
here what the pressure's been like over
the last
two months here you know they've been
intense i'm personally just back from
having corvette
so it's been a hard struggle i'm weak
i'm tired gotten back here we're busy
we're full every day we're struggling
but we're getting through it we have
good support here
so you caught it yourself yeah probably
working here right yeah
because i mean you've had it as well
yeah i survived the first wave but i
wanted to get it in this wave
about seven of us went off at the same
week so having seen
what kovig could do people coming in
here day after day when you got it
yourself
it must i was absolutely terrified i was
in hysterics on the phone ringing in
here
so how do you feel
for felix there's grief and terror and
he's not just lost his wife
his 40 year old son-in-law is also in
the hospital
on a ventilator in covert wards like
this one
recovery is uncertain but all the same
unconscious patients are being prepared
for it
we're now going to bend this left arm up
and touch your chin
physiotherapist claire is doing what's
called ranging
making sure the patient's joints don't
stiffen up so movement will come back
more easily
do you know whether they can hear you um
i just couldn't sometimes you hear from
our
previous survivors like they they say
they remember
like hearing accents rather than actual
words but i just think
you know this is you know he's a person
i'm going to tell him what i'm doing
so we're going to burn that up lovely
can't let these knees hips get this
sometimes it's easy to forget
that the people doing this kind of work
are day in
day out absorbing the horror of what's
happening in the room
you're working in an environment where
it's pretty much
unprecedented numbers of people dying
yeah and i just wonder how that feels
for you
um it's
i think this sounds silly but the worst
thing is when we do our ward books in
the morning
and it's when the amount of rips
outnumbers the ones that have made it
down to the wards
and i think that's when it really kicks
in and
they're a lot younger in the first wave
sorry i remember thinking that could be
mum
that could be my aunt and now i'm
thinking that could be me that could be
my brother
my boyfriend so yeah it's
hard and you you'll see
you're seeing those people every day
that you're working on and
really noticing the difference in their
age yes they're a lot younger this time
we lost people in their 30s in their 40s
it's heartbreaking
then it was straight back to work
tender care in a brutal environment
normality
a world away but where possible it is
invited in
by facetime at barnett's sister hospital
the royal free
the family of one patient on an
intensive care ward
allowed us to let you hear a video call
hey dad
i know you can hear us you can see your
eyes opening
so many people have just been asking
about you
he can hear he can hear he's opening his
eyes he can hear us
so many people love you so much
if only love and hope could cure
but in this alien environment he does
react
to the familiar voices
even as they speak in the bay opposite
another patient is lost the porters have
come
to take a man in his early 60s to the
mortuary
you've got a family over here yeah
talking to a loved one yeah and then you
at the same time you've got
someone being wheeled out who's just
died who presumably you've been caring
for yeah
so how does that feel it's really
upsetting i think on a
on sort of a daily level you're sort of
having to
talk to families and reassure them but
at the same time you might have patients
that are really sadly passing away
in literally the bay officer and it's
just trying to i think shield that from
patients and families and try and make
things look as normal as
as possible but it's really difficult
but it's not normal
no this is not normal this is not normal
at all
but these are the moments that make it
worthwhile
squeeze my hand again freezing tight
in another intensive care unit two
floors above
dima hooper is waking up give me a
thumbs up
you can hear me really well oh fantastic
53 years old she's an nhs caterer for
patients on wards
we don't want most of our patients to be
fully anesthetized we want them to
squeeze hands stick their tongue out
show that they're there
wriggle a little bit so what we're doing
there is moving from
a ventilator that does everything for
her to a situation where now she decides
when she breathes
this was last week a week on there's
more progress
it must be nice to be just sat up and
out of the bed
yeah you're feeling a lot better
yeah we look forward to when we can talk
to you properly
two days and then you'll be able to talk
oh
okay i won't push it but you've been
walking today
yesterday you started walking amazing
amazing you are incredible
you look strong last week we showed you
the moment nikolai yosachi first
responded to his
daughters after 40 days on a ventilator
he's a miracle
a week on he was getting ready to walk
are you feeling strong
you're feeling ready
[Music]
okay are you ready off we go
i was really taken back by how many
people were so debilitated like not just
physically but
we deal a lot with the cognitive side of
things and we'd have
patients who were like hugely you know
independent like
running their own businesses lawyers who
actually
were really confused and and couldn't
manage to do basic tasks
it's like a marathon yeah that you have
to train for
that's what we explain it to the
patients at samaras and the austrians
the same could be said for the work
being done by medics
like nikolai their progress is slow and
exhausting
but driven by hope jason farrell sky
news